[Music]
yo
my levels is good what's going on midway
what's up talk to me it's going down
it's going down you already know let me
know if my levels is good let me know
i'm sounding out here
i'm gonna get everybody in here have a
fun one
talk to me chat let me just make sure
the levels is good on the audio side
before i start bringing in the crew
you know before all the receptor
respectable people come in
on their sides of this battle
should be a fun one should be a real fun
one
macho what up hustle i see you what's
going on
dion 78 do they talk about playstation
xbox on the stream um
not right now this stream is for
supremacy this is for bragging rights
this is for
who is the goat which mass effect is the
goat that's what this is dion
you know what i'm saying thank you
what's going on okay asante what's up
you got your
you got your sword ready got your spear
sharpened because it's going down
it's going down we bringing it double tj
what's up thank you brother thank you
so yeah we going we got an all-star cast
man mass effect one and two
the big team all-star cast very
passionate marshall get out of here with
that mass effect right about to ban you
from the journey
to you i saw you on i saw you in there
you know young orbit what's going on
when you cover the halo
incident hmm incident i don't know what
you mean
describe subscribe
with the soldier that what
you're talking reckless i'm gonna keep
you on twitch over there with the
soldier
no doubt it's gonna be fun this is gonna
be fun
i got my shooters with me too they got
shooters too it's gonna be fun it's
gonna be fun so i'm gonna start bringing
them in
and um like i said we'll get the bell
running i think bill still will be
coming in hot during the joint we try to
make it fair
5v5 you know what i'm saying you know
cordial respectful but it's gonna get
intense you know
and at the end of the day even though we
we are both sides of this
very strongly we love this game so
that's what we have to keep the focus
that
even though we disagree vehemently we do
love this series so
that's gonna be the focus but uh i will
be back i'm gonna start getting people
in and uh get ready for a fun show yeah
i'm telling you
smoke is on all sides like if the smoke
is so real
like me and saul had to have a
gentleman's agreement before like
we could be called you right now but
it's all in sight but i see like that's
where this is at like
it's serious y'all poochie
what's going on what's going on big
poach what up
anyway see y'all in a minute i'ma start
grabbing people up and uh we're gonna
get this show on the road
15 minutes see ya
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
all right i'll read this super chat even
though i don't want to
lunk and lunker follow super chat i'm
glad we are all gathered today to
further discuss why me1 is the best of
the series
you could throw that wannabe cover
shooter every t that'd be two with the
bushes okay
i see what we doing with this but yeah
it's on we're gonna destroy
all this mass effect one garbage yeah
you're right
max effect two is a wannabe shooter and
mass effect one doesn't even want to be
a shooter
it wants to be i don't know what it was
don't even give him no [ __ ] don't
even get going
don't even give him that don't even give
him that don't give him no we we're
saving that for when he's real
showtime ainsley in the building
we'll be back y'all i just had to read
that uh super chat oh yeah t cox stand
up you already know
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
lovely
[Music]
all right and we are live
something new something different the
mast effect
debate show is live and first of all i
want to thank all these great gentlemen
have
made their time available for something
that's been a little contentious
in the mass effect community something
that as much as we love this franchise
this has been an
inner debate that has raged on for some
time
it's only right that we get all the
willing participants
to get this going man so let's start a
little bit with the introductions with
our uh tbass effect
one my man my brother from the third
grade lord
solve you've you've assembled the great
team there sir what's going on
i have i have uh this had to be done we
were just talking about the fact
that this is stuff that we used to do
back in the day when we were younger
um it would just happen sort of
impromptu and then there'd be a lot of
yelling and screaming and things of that
nature
um so it's always fun to sort of get
back to those roots
obviously in a respectful adult way yes
we are all the time
but uh yeah this is one of those
conversations that just keeps coming up
so it's fun to have
different opinions on both sides of it
and uh
we will have a winner i guess
so i guess like i said casual debate but
um what i wanted to do too is uh
introduce your team you know this
illustrious
team that you've uh constructed from
mass effect one
and i'll start with uh so you can you
set it off
so oh first off we have from
season gaming the man himself
lord ainsley bowden thank you so much
for coming through brother
much appreciated always amen
and then we have the lord of legality
himself
my cleanup hitter
[Laughter]
lord richard hogue thank you so much for
joining us absolutely we got to defend
the honor of the original
and then of course from the realm of
season games well as well
we have lord steve esposito which i was
not aware of the mass effect one love
i'm grateful and thank you you know the
kind of sight we run
indoctrination is already
[Laughter]
so thank you gentlemen for joining us
this is going to be fantastic this is
so much fun and for team mass effect
what will be coming hot will be the
legendary bill of course
he will be joining us coming in hot and
then we have
that mass effect 2 team that illustrious
team
on the right side of history bye bye
from
ign the legend debater and one of my
favorites from 5t chat
my man tie guy travis how we doing sir
mcclunkey happy to be here guys
and uh show those those old men
shouting at the clouds that uh me2 is
the superior game sorry guys go home
[Laughter]
and of course we have a good friend to
the realm my man
the man with the million gamer score
someone that you want to
respect that plays these games my man
ran out thor 19 from the xbox two what's
going on sir
what is going on [ __ ] what's going on
everybody and what's going on uh
peasants of the mass effect 1 realms
this is going to be your own team that
way that's crazy
so rude i can't believe that hey guys
let's take the mako for a spin huh
[Music]
the personal attacks are we getting into
it
are you are you indicating that your
ability to control the makeover was just
subpar is that a problem
that was everyone's ability to control
the makeup i'm not
again it's not my fault you're a basic
gamer oh we won't get into it
just just just letting you go guys know
that cog and i are very much used to
this type of smaller
so look and then also
we got one half of the dps podcast here
and member of the brat podcast panelists
as well as scub cast my man slobo
backslap how are we doing sir
how's it going cognito of the winning
team how are
you what's up travis what's up brand
what's up
you know i just wanted to say before we
get started just want to say that you
know
uh unlike our uh our opponents on the
other side that are relying on nostalgia
i have played have at least a dozen
playthroughs of this series
already so that i i unlike them
remember how this game played okay
and i unlike them will be bringing up
more than story in this debate
[Music]
um right
i'll
why attacking
tech really is is probably not the way
not the way you want to go
controls yeah i'll stop have stuff
played already
this is the game let's get through the
introduction
privilege here these guys are
representing opening statements here
i'll have you know the mass effect one
team did not abridge the rules
that is true that is it they did not
break the rules
we're men of culture there you go that
is true of mass effect 2 we are very
aggressive right now you know yeah
exactly i don't know why you would have
to be that aggressive
if you're that confident they're
flailing
they're blind
but wasn't the mass effect one team that
wanted to wait till after legendary just
move out when mass effect 1
they wonder why i wonder why are you
ever saying that i don't know
yeah yeah i wonder why aids was like why
are we doing it before but yeah
let's wait till mass effect one plays
like masterpieces
i'll tell you what i'm not at all
convinced the legendary mass effect one
will be better than the original so
we'll have that conversation we're gonna
get into it but we got
we got one more member and that's my man
again one half of the dps panel member
for brat podcast as well as comcast my
man
gaming forte who may or may not be
working so i just want to make sure he's
there is he still there right now
i'm still here right now my man my man
so i know like i said you
you have your time may be in and out
limited so it's up to you
how early you want to go but um so i'll
leave it up to you first um
let me get these super chats hold on let
me let me say something to song first
first of all
to to me one team i want to thank you
guys for coming to this show
because it takes some brave individual
souls to approach this conversation that
y'all about the broke
even you know i respect every last one
of you guys so you know even though
i may think your um your choice and
decision on what game is better may be
flawed and
crazy and ridiculous you're a mass
effect 3 guy i know
i respect you i respect you so uh thanks
for coming through and um
whole um drama to not bear not even be a
part of this conversation
i will address that earlier why don't we
get a drama presentation ready all right
[Laughter]
all right so sorry let's get this thing
going let's get to super chats uh we
have lunken
lunk and lunker with the five dollar
super chat i'm glad we're all gathered
today to further discuss why mass effect
1 is the best of the series
you can throw that wannabe cover shooter
me2 in the bushes
[Laughter]
i've been waiting all week i'm excited
for the show thank you sir
much appreciated then we have lucious
augustus five dollars super chat
as much as i will rock for every two i
will also never accept any slander for
the marco
excited to see this debate then we have
gaming types patrick once again five
dollar super chat slow mo
sounds like lord addict in disguise hmm
a little voice modulation going on there
addict uh then we have glorious kept
five dollars super chat there we go
mass effect 3 is the goat you're
oh glorious god three colors scared
three colors
then we have midway monster five dollar
super chat
it's gonna get messy friendships will be
tested digital blood will be spilled
have a great show i'll be yelling at the
screen with the mass effect 2 slanted
and gave you times patrick once again
with the two dollars which had me one
versus me2 feeling like apple versus
epic
oh then we have j ready with the five
dollar super chat let's keep it peaceful
dude we have metal detectors check
everyone love this show
oh then we have fonzo really gave me two
dollars we checked where's the andromeda
team
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'll put it on you man you guys could
could set it off first if you're like oh
shout out to i asked one more irish carp
5.50
canadian yes just dropping some love
lads happy saturday
thank you carpenter canadians man
all right
so um just to talk about like just just
to speak a little bit but just
about the game up front uh and what
happened um so
in 2007 bioware releases mass effect 1.
and what's interesting about mass effect
1 when it releases is
that it comes on not necessarily on the
heels but about two years after
we got the
end of the of the prequel trilogy in
star wars
and we got the last sort of star trek
tv thing neither of which were well
received right so all of a sudden you
have this
this sci-fi action rpg that's released
that sort of cribs a little bit from
both
and and also trying to sort of etch out
its own little niche of of what it is
and
at the same time what it's trying to do
as an rpg
is to sort of
bring an rpg to the masses where people
who are sort of afraid of the
the sort of the minutia of rpgs
could come to this game and look at it
and be like well it's a third person
shooter
but it's also this hardcore rpg that
appeals to that crowd
and i think what was great about mass
effect 1 is that it did
all of those things in spades it cripped
from both
star wars and star trek in ways that
gave it its own unique identity
and in the process turn this this rpg
into something that any type of gamer
could sort of gravitate to
and identify with um so the big things
that it did for me as a game was that
in terms of the lore oftentimes these
games with
with uh sort of huge backstories you
have
all kinds of other different things
where you get lore from right a
criticism i've had of destiny is
you know grimoire and stuff like that
and you having to seek out lore within
the game
that's not necessarily within gameplay
mass effect
throughout the course of that first game
you sort of get the entire
idea of what's going on in that world
right
the world building is is is excellent
in terms of uh teaching you the politics
of that world
what's happened in the past to sort of
get them to where they are
i think it does a fantastic job of doing
that
additionally when it comes to
hardcore rpg mechanics for a guy like me
who loves rpgs
it didn't dumb those things down right
it was very much a hardcore rpg where
you had to worry about your builds
you had to worry about your team's
builds and from build to build you could
play the game
very differently whether it was with
different weapons and their upgrades or
biotic
upgrades and things of that nature so it
did a lot to sort of advance
the rpg in ways that
people fans of the third person shooter
right in 2006 we had just gotten
gears of war and everybody was like oh
my god third person shooters and it was
able to sort of piggyback off of that to
sort of
bolster mass effect to another level um
so we'll get into the details later on
about the other specifics that that for
me
make mass effect 1 the superior product
let me add something to that absolutely
yeah so
let's remember too the history of the
actual game development right so bioware
as we classically knew them uh we won't
get into their more recent examples
uh anthem wise um but uh
you know bioware was a legendary
reputation right
uh for good reason and knights of the
old republic
to this day still considered one of the
greatest rpgs some people consider it
one of their favorite star wars things
of all time right very true so when
obsidian took over for
knights of the old republic too bioware
that team that core team that you know
fundamentally built that legendary
knights of the old republic that's the
team that came on and built
mass effect and so kind of going on to
what saab was saying is
you not only had this new
sci-fi universe that was built uh and it
took you through that entire journey and
what that universe was like
but you had the team behind that and the
elements behind it of what made knights
of the old republic great the
the style of combat the rpg elements all
those things and it's
you know i think that's a testament to
when you look back at both of those
games not that we're talking about
knightsville republic but you look back
at both of those games they are
legendary games from a developer that
really doesn't make games like that
anymore
hundred percent i i also just wanted to
say that
uh there at that time when those games
came out
i mean us hardcore bioware fans knew
about great storytelling and video games
but the vast majority of the gaming
community always looked at video games
as there's no such thing as good
storytelling in video games right right
fair point
and bioware with the way that they
approached it the the actual
visual aspect of what you're looking at
and what you're playing the
the cinematic nature to it the narrative
it really
almost kind of like how final fantasy 7
brought down fantasy to the forefront to
the casual community
mass this mass effect trilogy really
told the casual community that great
storytelling can happen in video games
yeah
and it was the first time where you
really
despite you know bioware's pedigree
already it was the first time they
introduced this idea of your
your choices really mattering right and
you
either choosing the paragon or the
renegade route and how that changes
the outcome of the of the game and well
not the outcome of the game
necessarily specifically but the route
you take to get there
um that was another thing that was
introduced there that again
because of the type of game it was and
the way it just
looked i think made it more attractive
to more people
and made it into this sort of phenomenon
that it might not have been if it was
just marketed or shown as this just as
hardcore rpg and nothing else
um so that i for me
that's sort of the beginnings of why i
think mass effect 1 is great i don't
know how you want to do this cog
we're going to point for point are
people going to talk all right we're
going to go point for a point but um
yeah once you once you get finished and
then you know i'll jump into
one of the mass effects so yeah so just
brief overview of of i guess the points
that i i think we all have on on this
side of this
is this game great because i'm hearing
all this and i'm not hey you know why
this game is great
great first off i'm not hearing about
what's these rpgs mechanics that y'all
talk about
okay first off you don't know what they
are you're not playing too much effect
shooters detailed rpg but
they're so beloved i don't think the
developers know what they are
no so
first off world building like i said
before
they gave you an entire world in one
game that you don't really need
outside context to understand you don't
100
and it happens through the conversations
it happens through just
the the interactions with with npcs you
understand the politics and the sort of
the ideologies behind people in this
world
and the big thing about that story wise
that i think make this
most compelling is that in this world
human beings are just now 30 years into
finding out that they're not alone in
this universe
and there is a fear amongst other races
that
the ascension of of human beings is
happening too quickly
right and so now it's the job of this
particular human being the specter
uh or person who becomes a specter
shepard to sort of
show the quality of humanity right
and what's interesting about that story
is is that it
it puts it it gives
humans an antagonistic tilt while still
making you the protagonist and the hero
right but throughout the world you see
why people don't necessarily trust
humans specifically
in the primary antagonist of the game
sarin
saren is very much a compelling
character because
he is a tyrion who hates humans
he hates humans in everything they stand
for
at the same time the decisions that he
makes initially seem like
it's just deployed to eliminate
humankind and humanity
and if you were on saren's side saran
sees
yes that that will be a happy accident
as part of what i'm doing
but at the same time i am also trying to
create a world where organics matter
with this impending sort of uh machine
sort of revolution that's coming that i
think is is inevitable that it's coming
so in terms of the antagonist i think
mass effect ones win a hundred percent
then you add to that
the reaper sovereign who's controlling
everything from what's your namesake
with your dave's sake
no well he bit for me i'm the original
that's the emotional connection exactly
no no not at all
i get out of emotions emotions we get it
by where you're gonna have an emotional
connection as
does kevin sorbo kevin sword also owes
me money because
i guess
got too much debt i'll never see a check
there
um so i
for me that antagonist is crazy because
when you look at me 2 me3
it's just basically it's the reapers at
the core of everything but there's no
one person or entity you can point to
for i would disagree for mass effect 3
the elusive man
is the the main people the elusive man
as well as uh
his uh his assassin uh my camera
they built them up through the books and
then they introduced them in mass effect
3.
and uh harbinger in mass effect 2
you would probably say with the lucid
man also
pulling the strings in the background as
well you know you can't trust the
elusive man from the very very start of
the game so you know that he is not
someone that even though he appears to
he to be on your side and oh shepherd
great job on that mission but really
you know what he's doing in the
background i i think that
and this this may be if you look at it
across all three games
you're looking at good and tagging this
with really poor final battles
for all three games
spiders uh sarin
final battle hold on hold on wait a
minute the epic hold on what's happening
at the same time as the star battle and
the sovereign and the attack you're not
that one yeah
once again
and then you realize he's been
indoctrinated the entire time
right basically he's been a puppet for
sovereign talking through him this
entire time
he turns into spider sarin and he starts
bouncing off
doesn't that make him more competitive
one of my team anyone on my team retort
the idea that
steven yeah let's let's go all right
first of all
let's address the whole sarah and commit
suicide thing
that's only if you get your that's a
skills that's one
version that's not necessarily the
version you have to actually work on
your skills your communication
and get that all the way up you know in
an rpg you know that's not number two
i'm rpgs i want to hear the details i
haven't heard that why why is it rpg
i'll go into the rpg moment for a second
okay first of all you got an array of
weapons you know it's not just the
regular weapons
you have weapons from different
companies and each company has different
stats and stuff
so when you're looking at the weapons
you gotta think about hey what do i want
do i want faster firepower
do i want to use the sniper rifle plus
you also have the classes and each class
is kind of divided so
you have the soldier class you can use a
bit of everything you have like the
sentinels you can use like the biotics
and stuff so it all depends
that all kind of fuses into this
interesting gameplay of what do you want
to play as
just quick [ __ ] so basically you're
saying that the rpg mechanics are
restrictive weapons per class that only
certain
classes and individuals can use certain
things and be locked out of them that's
what we're considering true rpg
mechanics
come on i got to build this out
on mass effect 2b no i'm asking you i'm
just saying
my question is it is mass effect 1 is
the true rpg
because it's restricted
why is that good why is that good why is
that you're freaking out
you're picking up this much
okay i need to push back on everything
you guys are saying because it's crazy
it's like you played a different game
okay the main villain
is not not sarin oh dude it's his
ship okay that's like finding out that
like the horse that the sheriff is
riding was the real bad guy the whole
time like it's a ridiculous are you guys
really trying to come in here in south
park hold on hold on
parker's like i'm above the light okay
so seriously
it's a block of
guys make it to see
and they're crap ninja but what is the
antagonist at me too
the uh
oh my goodness that's just some stuff i
was keeping notes from before
better then you got bears great i feel
personally attacked
i see bears
rpg element stuff yes everything that
that that steven brought up about how
you got these restrictive elements and
all the different classes if i want to
be a soldier i can do this if
i if i'm gonna be a vanguard i can't use
certain weapons uh
steve tell me why for the legendary
edition they undid all that yes
15 year old game and we all played it
already that's why
gameplay calibrations from ea from
bioware themselves
and you just said it you just
that we should abide by the legendary
edition changes because
modern bioware is that much better than
mass effect one era
is that actually i am that's not
accurate what i am
saying is that the the actual developers
who made the game
really make the original game they're
not the same developers they're not
some of them are like mike yeah
he's a part of this he is now look so
mike gamble realized
he did all of this they realized that
this stuff was bad the mako controls the
accuracy
bad the cover shooting abysmal horrible
stuff yeah horrible okay so okay so the
rpg mechanics
the rpg mechanics are not a virtue you
guys are like oh they've got all these
weapons but they're
they're not fun and i'll tell you this
though i'll tell you this like they were
like
let's do that borderlands random loot
thing except for every guns
if they're not a virtue then why did
they bring him back for mass effect 3
why did what bring back for mass effect
mass effect 3 the the
game literally any conversation you look
about development from bioware says yes
we heard our fans in mass effect 2 we
removed way too much so we brought
things back for three
if they're not if they weren't wanted
then why the hell did they bring them
back if mass effect 2 was so good
this whole idea that like dude i get on
this about destiny too like oh more guns
is good it's like that's not true
you're not answering the question halo
has not answered my question
okay so here's the answer here's the
answer uh it was a mistake
and oh so now bioware's wrong okay okay
yes they're wrong did you play mass
effect 3 or andromeda
let me ask you this let me ask you this
if bioware
isn't gobbled up by by
ea going into mass effect 2
do you think the changes that were made
to mass effect 2
in terms of how they streamlined it
would have occurred
hell no not a chance my recollection is
that is that
i bought uh bioware right near the end
of development that the game was
basically like
more than halfway that was two that's
the end of development of one
yeah yeah that was the second one if you
look at if you look at the history of
bioware
um when they first started with ea all
of their games from like
dragon age um awakenings dragon age two
definitely dragon age two which only had
a 15-month cycle right
um all of those games were basically
they had very hard end dates like you
have to end this because i want your
team working on this something else
like immediately and they they really
never really gave them a lot of time so
that is true
that if there was they were crunched for
time but that's literally for like
all of these games that we're talking
about except for mass effect 1
which honestly with the way those
controls were they should have gained a
little bit more time on that
but anyway i mean like it's just that
you know that's how ea is
ea didn't give them a ton of time there
right like
i get that i'm sorry i want to get hog
and bills we got to get them in because
they haven't good gotcha together
sure did you call on me i'm sorry don't
please 100 oh no absolutely i just
wanted to underline and put an
exclamation point on something saab said
because
i think he did a great job explaining
the plot explaining how obviously as we
can all agree seren's a wonderful bad
guy with sovereign
as his wonderful ship but more
importantly than the specifics
i'm not interested in the role-playing
mechanics i know you want to talk about
them i don't care i'm not interested in
the mac oh
i don't care all you don't do my money
playing knight's the old republic
jade empire dragon age mass effect 1
whatever it is i don't play role-playing
games for their mechanics i played final
fantasy
you don't play it for the airplane got
it no i don't i don't play it's
turn-based you hit attack you try to get
through
it's about building up a story and mass
effect
one i think saab didn't put enough
emphasis
on the creative difficulty of building a
world
to such granular detail that every bit
of plot
every bit of character everything that
you do every place that you see every
race that you meet builds
on itself to create a world that is
happening not just on your screen but
outside the borders of the screen not
just in the encyclopedia entries which
are awesomely voiced
and one of my favorite little like
encyclopedia codices
in the history of video games but
everywhere all at once
and everything that came after mass
effect 1
is built on what they built in that game
you want to talk about why mass effect 1
is better than mass effect 2.
it's because mass effect 2 is great it's
fun game love it
but it is built off of the shoulders of
giants
what they did with mass effect 1 going
in doing the homework
every single thing that is missing in
the modern age of
cinema and very often video games
whether it's the disney star wars
trilogy or
you know anything disney really that
lacks that world building that lacks
that detail that doesn't allow you to
invest yourself
in the story to get involved so when you
see
those reapers coming from between
galaxies
that you think about the rest of the
trilogy and you're disappointed when you
don't really address that story
in mass effect 2 and maybe you have a
nice little side journey that doesn't
really go anywhere and we
i agree with what most of hulk says
right i think it's
i think it's a it's an accomplishment of
bioware for building that universe the
way they did it is it is the biggest
reason why mass effect
is great in my opinion and yes i'm going
to praise mass effect 1 even though i'm
on mass effect 2 because i understand
that without mass effect 1 we don't get
a mass effect 2 right
but there are still some issues i have
with mass effect that
the sequels improved upon i think
everybody here for the most part will
agree
that the combat is extremely clunky mass
effect one to the point where
they're gonna make it like mass effect
two the pacing is inconsistent
the exploration in the mako is copy
paste it controls horribly
like one of the biggest things i was
looking forward to mass effect was
exploring these worlds but then you
actually get to explore the world
and they're just the same things they're
barren the side quests are just
they're the same exact thing but what it
does well
is build that universe right where it's
like this overarching plot of like here
come the humans
here's the citadel here's all these
races here's the history
sarin is the best villain in the mass
effect universe and he's a very
sympathetic when you actually kind of
realize
what he's trying to accomplish he's
trying to like sort of bring peace
between the reapers and everybody so
like
i get that but mass effect 2 is a better
game
overall and i'm not even going to touch
on like
how uh you know the combat's better
uh so it's an actual better game you can
actually have a better experience
playing it for 40 hours
and i because it's the story that
gripped me in mass effect 2. the story
is much more personal and messages
which is why it's a better it's a better
game for at least for me right
mass effect 1 it's a galaxy spanning
game it's about the
the uh you know us versus the reapers
and it introduces the world which is
great but
mass effect 2 takes it to a personal
level and usually most
more personal stories are better right
you get
these characters and i understand
there's the lack of urgency in mass
effect 2 right you have the collectors
but then you spend a lot of your time
going to to do the uh loyalty missions
right
but that's why the game's better because
you spend all this time with your crew
all 12 of them
characters are all better than mass
effect one
you get to understand who they are what
makes them tick right
their their goals for the future their
uh you know their fears right
and then you set up a situation where
you're you're they're your crew and then
it actually goes into the final battle
where
you you run the suicide mission the
greatest mission of all time
everything in video games everything the
greatest
oh
of what mass effect was trying to
accomplish right mass effect 1 didn't
have that
right and i'll give you seren's a better
villain i'll give you
that the sovereign reveal is probably
the best five minutes
in the entire mass effect trilogy where
you know he's
like you finally understand what was
really going on like those five minutes
are the best
scene yes but the the the purse the
the personal connections to the
characters
the loyalty missions and then all
leading up to
okay we need to basically have a mission
here where everybody can dine everybody
can die if you screw it up if you didn't
do the loyalty missions
you didn't put them into their clueless
i'm not gonna be aggressive on this but
can i make a comment on the suicide
mission because i
i've always found this to be interesting
i i've understood now
watching everything on the internet and
seeing everybody play it that you can
screw it up
i just kind of paying attention to who
could do what didn't lose a person
in the suicide mission and i think that
at least a lot of people's experiences
was maybe not not losing anyone
but not losing many people like if
you're paying attention they call it a
suicide mission for the whole game
and i really didn't find it to be that
damaging to my crew or at stakes
did the mass effect 2 team i mean did
you find that you lost people did you
have more of that because
it came down to besides the fact the
loyalty missions and that relationship
that you built with each individual
character
you also had to position them in the
right spaces based on their skill set
right
so it was it was a combination of both
factors and the fact that
every single member i got you steve i
know you've been patient
you know every single member like i said
had a role you built this relationship
so
the the coolest part about it was that
if you were a complete idiot as well
yeah shepherd could die you know say so
that was interesting but i wouldn't i
would guess because steve but yeah
and then we'll get back all right so
yeah let's talk about those
characterizations here
in that world the uh incredibly
condensed thing did you have fun
shooting mines
onto other planets as your exploratory i
love that situations
you guys have all of these opinions
based on the game that came out three
years later
you didn't feel that way when you played
the game oh i hated it right now
i didn't hold a hold on fraud i didn't
hate
being on the left let me get you i'm
talking no
y'all love math the thing with mass
effect lovers one lovers
y'all love the illusion of an rpg that
is not a
true opportunity that isn't an illusion
it's the same bland blue and red colored
planets
with awful controls off the makeup was
terrible and it's the same sand monster
that you fought
you like the illusion you like the
illusion
of the position
no man's sky at launch thank you those
mercenaries this is the thing those
mercenaries
there's one constructor a builder out
there who got rich off of all these
mercenaries that was the election
how was it i'm like i go take on a whole
different group and they got the same
exact base layer
copy pasted buildings the same whack
redundant sand monster it was it was
awful
when it came out hold on let me shoot
him i fell in that way
that's my exploratory i
you're going to talk about the
characterizations listen yeah you got to
be an idiot to [ __ ] up the whole
whole ending you got to be really stupid
because i've played that game
countless times never lost a guy never
or you can just not do the side quests
like lots of people don't do the side
quests yeah why would you not be a
cyclist when that's the only content
available yeah and that's
what you just said that's the best
content that you have that is the
content
i don't think there's
did a very eloquent speech about the
loyalty missions
the reason why i think mass effect 2 is
better i look at it and the loyalty
missions are awesome i don't think
we're doubting anything but all you guys
keep saying is bland
bad controls yeah so it's fake rpg
but this is the thing so that means that
means your fundamental argument
is that the game that came out three
years later
looks runs and plays better than the
older one
and it was more fun it was a more fun
game
the obvious improvements you would get
is
i mean i mean like look your argument is
that
mass effect 1 set up the lore the
all of that stuff no that's
participating part of
but no one says that uncharted one is
better than uncharted two
way better than that game everything
that you're talking about about the
universe
but this is is in massive this is the
argument that we have no way
you want me to you're actually giving
you an argument that analysis is flawed
you know why
because when you take when you take
uncharted one
and you look at the through line to
uncharted two you see the improvements
there you see
what was missing in one that's improved
upon and two
for me again and this is a subjective
thing exactly what's next
that's semblance of a improvements for
me it's for me
for me and probably a lot of the guys on
my panel
one specialist the things that made mass
effect one special
were absolutely eliminated in two and
that's my issue with you
right the grandeur the grandeur of what
they were attempting to do in one
right rather than expand on it in two
they looked at it and said we're cutting
this yeah mass effect 1 was bloated it
was like 30 hours longer than it should
have been
it's it's you exploring all of these
planets and doing side quests that
aren't fun
he's saying you know ain't said that you
turned it into a single button shooter
okay well at least it's something mass
effect 1 did not know what it was it's
you guys are talking about how the
virtues and that's what makes you
comfortable you're talking about that's
what makes it
designed at all that doesn't have any
sort of like
like sandbox designed around its weapons
it's it's basic it's just it's you
sometimes you have to trim
fat to actually make a focused story and
mass effect 2 does that wonderfully
does mass effect 2 has a focus story
that's your position
completely focused on
doing
you're doing everything for a single
mission it's we got to do this mission
we're assembling the crew it's that
thing
no no it's a very focused that has a
finale right
and a bunch of episodes
it's them creating a contrived scenario
contrived scenario so you can feel for
these characters
yep and it's a contrived scenario
there was no character development there
was no character development
this is the thing everything else around
it the story the overarching story
didn't matter
all this that's the [ __ ] i killed it
hold on hold on i guess
because it is stated in mass effect 3.
it's stated by the one prothean that's
still a lie
that this you get the cycle everything
everything
that happened into with them taking the
humans and repurposing them this is what
they did to the protheans this is what
they do every cycle
this would have happened where their
shepherd failed at the end of mass
effect 1
or not and that protein also said that
the war
started before he was even born the the
reapers took
over a century to eliminate
the previous advanced civilizations
this would have happened regardless so
the argument that
mass effect 2 was pointless it would
have never happened it should never
happen
it's false that's not the argument
you're arguing from inside the universe
are you familiar with the term retcon
because you're bringing that's not a
retcon or whatever
so many problems with storytelling
it's been interesting to hear because i
have no idea where you all started from
um because i'm also not like i'll say
rand
congrats for having like the most
coherent thread oh
my god so i joined even though i don't
agree with you
um like all i think it's interesting
because i don't know
saab i apologize like i'm in the mass
effect one camp but not because i want
to tear down
two things not at all i don't know
but when we get to one guys no no no
stop one guys can't give two
any credit it burns their soul
it's first and soul it says credit
actually he just tried to be nice now
for the company
you guys can acknowledge mass effect
once set up an amazing universe of
characters
cannot even but that's why we think it's
better that i mean i wish you were the
ones
[Laughter]
listen here's the deal mass effect 1 for
me
was a more coherent and concise story
that created urgency
what was going on with like it was when
you sat down not knowing
where this was gonna go not knowing what
you were gonna do because it was a new
world it was a new experience it drove
a really really strong story i loved
mass effect 2
as well but i'm sorry it was also this
sort of casual dating sim
where you just had to run around and
build out your life story with all your
friends
before the game ended and if you didn't
do that
it lost all of its urgency which it
didn't have much of to begin with
and i acknowledge it's a better game
right in terms of okay
we did it we're there played oh no
we're having definitional problems cog
because he doesn't mean game like you
mean game he said he's better
the place is closed
he said it's a better game
i heard what i needed like
tech gets better all the time right and
so games improve
in terms of visual fatality control
fidelity now i also think
everybody talking crap about the mako
and on the base it wasn't that bad it
was pretty bad
could be in front of you and you
couldn't hit that enemy accurately
just because you were on a higher
platform what are you doing
man these guys are tired
this way i think mass effect 1 story was
a better story
okay and i think it did more for driving
an
end-to-end narrative so that when you
finish that game you're ready to play it
yeah you were ready to move on to
another do another experience it was
complete it was whole
i love mass effect 2 as well but it's
the difference between star wars
and attack of the clones right it may be
no they
look better it may have better special
effects it may be its own story that
builds out on the future
but the individual story from mass
effect 1
had a sense of urgency and drive from
start to finish
that i don't think two came anywhere
near two there was too
much time burned into where it pulled
you out of that story
because you had to go run the other sets
of
learning about what was driving me hey
baby you're driving around and what do
you want to go learn about your home
like i'm sorry it just took too much out
of so
that very tight story loop and made it
into the left let's get miranda
let's get miranda i want to hear from
miranda
so let's let's just come at this from
actual fact that we actually know of
mass effect 2 so way more than one
income
no just just numbers just numbers i
i can only speak from my own personal uh
experience inside of mass effect
i play i rand is 100 right the
it felt like mass effect 1 to me was the
experiment
that they were trying to accomplish when
they wanted to like build this
this grandiose shooter and tie these rpg
elements into the game
with the promise of this space
exploration that was gonna
go beyond and you go bowling where no
other man has gone before because like
you said earlier saw
it came right after we just got through
with the prequels with
uh with on star wars and we had just
finished the last star wars when it came
to the tv series and stuff
so they were really banking on that
being the hallmark that like get people
to want to really care about
the story that was going to happen in
this game the problem for me was
you were in you stayed in that citadel
like what was it four or five hours in
the citadel
running around being stuck on elevators
for half a half of
half a century the whole release okay it
did we don't even okay
they said
was in one corridor listen so to me like
i said
so to me once you left the citadel i was
expecting like this
this the world to just open up and guess
what you do
like there's some great parts in mass
effect one like the whole
wreck scene when you you know gotta make
your decision you gotta make a decision
there were some amazing decisions that
had to happen
inside of mass effect one before you
even got the best effect too but guess
what a lot of people
didn't even get to that point because
guess what i i can only speak for myself
and the people in my circle
a lot of people drop mass effect when i
try to get them into the series
as soon as they as soon as they got out
of the citadel and the world opened up
it was like
what the hell do i do but you go around
to these planets and you land on them
and there's nothing to do
you've got this one there's one
stationary station in there that you got
to go through
and these dumb turrets and then you're
dealing with the crappy mako and
everything
so people like you know what i'm done
but guess what happened but guess what
happened
three years later
listen i made an actual release
effect 2 came out and all of the things
like my brother told me i wasn't even
interested and i was like no i couldn't
stand the first one because of how they
were
they did the rp they did the elements
inside the game and he was like yo
play the second one and literally all i
did was the
first mission that was like yo this
already has
i got to i was waking up on the table
and they was like you got to create your
character and everything and i was like
oh no i'm not doing this i gotta go play
master effect one
so i can bring my character going
forward to play this so
for me and a lot of people like me it
took the experience of seeing what the
promise of mass effect 2
could be versus what we already saw in
mass effect one
and then that speaks in the numbers of
the people that bought it because guess
what
massive you wouldn't think that people
wait you would think that people would
say mass effect 3
would be it probably would sell better
than mass effect 3 it best
the first one but guess what mass effect
1
still sold better than mass effect 3 so
and
massive three it's considered to be the
better version of a game
overall now wait a minute that's like
that's not that's not unique though in
the industry for a new franchise to take
time to become established
but then become successful and draw a
much larger audience in on its sequel
no and i was going to relax too like i
mean that's not irrelevant doesn't imply
most people
there's a reason that i can literally i
can literally walk out right
literally walking myself for right now
and ask just a random person that
that knows nothing if they know anything
about mass effect
i guarantee you eight out of ten people
are going to tell you that
yo mass effect 2 was like i don't know
what
what crack they were on when they made
that game but it was incredible
there was random people i was in a party
with cognito we were playing uh
gambit and the dude texted me and i said
oh i like your icon he had the n7
helmet on this on his profile my man
texted me back he's like bro
i am so hyped for that game coming out
next week mass effect 2 over
everything that's all like we know it's
universally important that is the
universe
i thought we were talking about why are
we just yelling about opinions what is
this so
it's all opinions well listen it's all
[Laughter]
i'm sorry get ahold get this stupid well
i mean it's not a role-playing game that
sells the most games every year
it's call of duty yeah they made it they
made fantastic
more call of duty yeah that's great it's
true
not true
that's what activision did to destiny
well it made it a better game though
made it a better better game i mean i
mean mass effect
it's it's like bill already said mass
effect 2 is a better game than mass
effect 1 doesn't make it a better rpg
establishment
wait another question for me today let
me answer why does
what can anybody tell me a reason why
mass effect 1
even exists inside this trilogy it
doesn't even have to exist
yeah it does it sets them up that's no
it's a storytelling
yes why are bug creatures coming down
all of a sudden there's no reason for
the big one
american education all right
number two
they get to talk about everything about
mass effect 2 and how it makes them feel
that has nothing that has nothing to do
with the situation without
trying to talk about mass effect 1. mass
effect 2 guys you just got to stand up
and just give yourself
the reasons
what time does this end because i feel
like everyone talk about mass effect 2
well it's better
guess what you're just trying to run
that clock out man
i gotta talk about the mako for the
eighth time in a row because that's the
only problem that i had with the game
you know you just gotta keep on going
with that kind of stuff
and then travis okay so let me ask you
this question then
yeah all we've heard and all we
typically hear in this debate is that
mass effect 1's mechanics were dated and
they are i think we're awful yeah we
yeah
please stay awful 100 percent okay
they're clunky yes not arguing okay not
arguing cool
so all we ever hear from you guys the
me2 guys is
they streamlined it they made it better
the action's better into
it's a better game right and removed
removed unnecessary and unfun
mechanics from i have more to say but i
haven't really set my piece yet well i
also said mass effect
i don't even ask you a question yet if
that's your case
because that's all we've heard so far
that's the one that's not our case
if that's not just our case though
that's the beginning of the end for you
i said i haven't heard anything else
okay no because y'all thinking that's
all we got i'm just waiting for y'all to
remember he says
i said that's a better story too i mean
if that's your case
then why is me3 not the better game
which has better shooting
than two better cover mechanics than two
better abilities than two
better combat than two everything that
you guys love about two
over one is better in three than it is
two
i can answer that i can answer that i
can answer that as well slowly
you got it uh i have more statement the
only reason that we argue that one is
the best
outside of those mechanics is because
when you look at like bill said
so i've said steve said when you look at
the overall arc
of the story the antagonist how it fits
the universe the development of the
story narrative
through a game one is the best
and when you're talking about an rpg
which you have to worry about behind oh
yeah yeah still haven't defined what
this
great rpg i've been waiting yeah i've
been waiting
what is the great rpg mechanics of this
game
no need to do it customization customize
customize your builds the guns also
again by limiting and restricting
absolutely
you can do that in every single mass
effect
you can change shepard in the rest of
the crew's abilities
where you just want to spec into which
abilities you want to max out you can do
that in literally every single way
does it matter in the same way
i still didn't answer my question does
it matter
about what about does it matter in the
same way that okay
well hold on let me answer ames question
okay all right
okay so the reason why mass effect 2 is
still better than mass effect 3.
for a lot of people it's the ending but
let me go outside at the end because the
ending
really it's the end of the trilogy it
really ruined it for a lot of people
because we were
we were kind of marketed and told
different ways
i think we're i think we're all i think
we're all in an agreement yeah yeah
right but but but outside of that the
crew that they introduced
for three was subpar compared to one and
two
uh the the characters were the new
characters in your crew were not
compelling or interesting whatsoever
and then also you had
basically the mass effect two characters
that well master effect one characters
that came back again
but there was really nothing more to
really explore with their stories in
three
and then you would see your some of your
mass effect 2 crew again
but is really was just wrapping up what
was already established in mass effect
2.
three head as you said great controls
great combat and and it looked better
than both of the previous two games had
great little moments like shepard
and gom um shepard and the crew taking
on the elusive man at his base
those were great moments the running
towards the uh the teleporter
before the the reaper shoots you down at
the very end
great moments but it all falls apart
because the overall
ending of the game correct just let
everyone down
and that's our taste yeah now
if i could can real quick i'll give you
my argument of why me too is better than
me once let's go slow
so the kind of piggy back over what ran
said about
the story and being personal and and
getting to know your crew
i disagree with the assertion that there
is no
tension that there is no like pace to it
that there's no
giddy up hurry up kind of feel if you
notice
that if you do trigger certain
actual like main missions before
you do all the loyalty quests in mass
effect 2 you will have
no time to finish them before your crew
starts to get liquidated
by the collectors correct you have to do
things in a certain order
do you notice that you could get
someone's loyalty for example
you could get miranda's loyalty do her
loyalty quest
then if you do jack's loyalty quest they
get into an argument
yes and if you don't have enough
renegade or paragon points
to defuse the situation whoever you
choose
you lose the loyalty of the other right
that kind of
dilemmas they don't occur in mass effect
interpersonal relationships
yeah i mean it's an rpg mechanic by the
way yeah that's actually
yeah the only one that happens in the
first one no it's more but we still have
something
in that in mass effect one is with rex
with rex
yeah that's it wait wait look it's with
just hey bill this is the dating sim in
mass effect 1.
actually all the bioware games are
dating sims i mean
you can get some romance so you play
some dragon they look i got caught up
with my wife
my wife came in the room when in dragon
age where my warden was was about to get
down with uh
with a liliana i was like hey
fundamental
role-playing games for different reasons
yeah but this is the thing i think in
mass effect 2.
i just want to want to finish up what i
was saying okay i think
something that we haven't even mentioned
yet is the dlc and that is a part of the
package as well
i don't know oh that's not part of the
game
afterwards that's not part of that game
now
you're scared yeah
we can't talk about it
oh
the fact that you need shadow broker to
put you over the hump no oh no
no yeah hey you guys are brokers that's
just
packing on points on our lead i'm just
saying
i didn't bring up dlc what do you mean
our massive brethren are very fear of
the dlc
mass effect 2 is so fast
so i would like to okay obviously like
okay
i work i do reviews for a living so this
is all
subjective like everybody's got
everything this is awesome none of them
are right you guys keep saying facts
like facts
have no place when it comes to creating
a video
like for me it does all the things that
i think it responds to feedback you guys
are throwing around the oh ea changed it
they made a call of duty i think that's
kind of a disingenuous argument because
what they really did is they took things
that worked in mass effect 1 and they
kind of dove deeper and one of the
things that i think people wouldn't like
mass effect 1 as much as they do
if they didn't have those characters
that you could kind of dive into those
conversations with
but you never got to go all the way you
know have a few conversations with rex
and then every time you meet him he's
just like shepard rex
shepard you know that whole thing and
and i think mass effect 2 expanded on
that you guys are calling it a dating
sim but i call it a character
exploration which is one of the main
reasons people play bioware games
and then the things that didn't work
like the open world stuff and
and you know the worlds that we kind of
you know we've we've talked about that
plenty
they scaled that down and took it away
and tried to make it a more focused game
and for me
mass effect 2 respects your time and is
a more focused story
does it stand on the shoulders of the
giant that is mass effect 1
absolutely but it is a new hope to mass
effect 2's empire strikes back it is
it doesn't just because it came first
and set up does not
make it a better game on its own mass
effect 2
it benefits from mass effect 1. you get
to kind of
all the decisions you made in mass
effect 1 carry over you could have an
all-human counsel
when you get to mass effect 2 that stuff
is really cool but in mass effect 2 you
also have the consequences
of your actions in that game rather than
mass effect 1 where they sort of punt
and go
okay all the decisions you made you're
going to see the results of that in the
next game right
mass effect 2 benefits from that in
being the middle piece and i think that
that's
a unique advantage that it has but
overall like obviously we all love mass
effect
mass effect 1 is a great game but
there's a lot of stuff that it doesn't
do well i don't think that the rpg
mechanics are a virtue
i don't think that the gameplay is
benefited by it i think that they
probably could have used the slim down
and i think that decision mass effect 2
is a good decision whether it was made
by bioware or not like whoever was in
the back room who made that decision i
think it was the right call
um and i think that you guys are going
to see in mass effect 1 remastered
that it's going to be a better game it's
going to be a better game you're more
focused
they're going to have brought in some of
that stuff so here's why star wars
analogy is a bad one
because empire strikes back is
incredible it's incredible
because it dives in and really shows
the empire striking back for lack of a
better phrase but it really puts vader
right that's what made vader that epic
presence
mass effect 2 doesn't have that the epic
presence in story when it comes to mass
effect is sarin
and sarin is a mass effect 1. so you
trying to say that it went from new i
don't think i don't think empire strikes
back which really develops the core
antagonist of the entire star wars
universe
who lives on 45 50 years later uh
there's nothing like that in mass effect
2. yeah so i mean i mean you can argue
about about like the
you know the actual story and what
empire strikes back does but the the
point is that empire
doesn't have to worry about war built
world building because it had a new hope
that did that
and so it allows it to focus it allows
it to focus on the story that they want
to tell whereas mass effect 1
is sort of distracted by the fact that
they're trying to simultaneously build
the world and tell a story and i think
that something gets lost in that aspect
too can just say
all right the world's here everyone
knows it so let's just tell a focus
story today
empire strikes back is the is the is the
movie that builds the universe
out in star wars that's where all the
world building actually comes in star
wars if you look at it from 1977
is very very weak in terms of its
overall world building it's one scene
talking about the senate and the
galactic empire when you get to empire
the reason it's so successful is because
of that world expansion the reason mass
effect 2 is not
is because it condenses everything you
had a grand space opera
you had a discussion of alliances and
politics and councils and all of this
and then you shrink it down and yes that
can work better for some i'm not going
to take that away
from thor's and passion speech about why
it works better for him
i think that's great i think it's not
the story that they projected they were
going to tell
when you get to the end of mass effect 1
and you see the reapers out there this
is going to be epic this is going to be
a
kick-ass story and we're going to break
it down and tell that dating sim that
you like
more which is fine but it's a different
type look what you did bill look what
you did i'm glad i had
something here no but if the story was
so conclusive in two like
like hogue's saying right then why do
you continue that in three
the elusive man and that kind of that
setup
he's the man never really to hoag's
point earlier the end of
two as much as people like this suicide
mission that's not even necessarily a
suicide match
continuously have respect
but there's there's no culmination to
that level
like dealing with saren and the end of
that i think the ceremony is over i
don't think sarin was a good animal i
don't think he was a good
he's a he's a glorified boy in the
sovereign attack was a good ending
because mass effect
i will tell you this one thing that
jumped out at me when i was getting told
the numbers of sales
is a notion when you're looking at media
sales that
the sins of the father visited upon the
sun the sequel
sells by the momentum of the prequel
that empire strikes back is positive
because of star wars that the second
pirates of the caribbean
is positive because of the first you
tell me those sales numbers
what i see there is momentum pure raw
momentum from the end of mass effect 1
that gets everybody excited combined
it should be noted with an electronic
arts throwing money at the marketing i
don't know if you remember mass effect
2's marketing it was right
that's awesome that's awesome that they
got that but it throws it into mass
effect 2 and then what i see
is a stall in that momentum you get to
the end you fought collectors you fought
a skeletor thing maybe people enjoyed it
when it happened but you get to the end
and you're like
i guess okay and there's no momentum
going into the sales of mass effect
i mean you shouldn't go by sales numbers
for if your game is good
if that's gonna be used as been evidence
against me i mean i would never use it
all right here's the thing in this small
beauty sells better
this momentum the thing that we're
forgetting is the the fact that the
elusive man
presented an interesting character from
the sense of this was a person who was
essentially a human supremacist
and this was a person who presented you
with a choice at that
moment with this human reaper tech
right that we have a choice to say okay
we can use this to control
the reaper so a decision was made it was
a very important decision
besides all of the suicide mission going
on and the other thing about
you know the story is so much better
massive one no doubt we're never gonna
take away the world building from mass
effect one
but it expanded so much better into from
you you talked about the krogan
homeworld of tachanka
you talked about the xenophage you you
almost had
racism between aliens you had you know
what i'm saying the solarius the whole
xenophage that whole thing
you have people all the politicians all
of the glory you have the qurans the
death
you you had literally all in one
get traffic i was gonna say like there's
a lot of stuff we we haven't even talked
about like the fact that the characters
just are better in massachusetts
i'm sorry like forget about jordan solis
morton solis is iconic
uh garrus went from being a mall cop to
being a badass bounty hunter like they
did
really cool stuff with the characters
and i think that like
why are you playing a bioshock game so
you can roam around the world and look
at the
you know the stuff that it decorates
itself with or are you there because
space operas are all about
the why the relationship and the the
people you meet along the way and the
struggles that they're going with
but this is the very first first the
first game the first game presented
the first game presented a scenario
where they if you felt coming out of
that that they were going to give you
both
i loved all of the loyalty missions in
two
right but for me that that part of it
is the ideal sort of evolution from what
they had in one to me
that is an aspect of what i expected
from two not the crux of it
and that is what bothers me about how
they moved onto two i mean travis talked
about
this the way they were building and
trimming the fat the thing is i think
there's a big distinction between the
way you world build in a game
and the way you would world build in a
movie right whereas where you can have
one one thing that initiates it all that
gives you the general idea of what the
whole world is
and then you can focus specifically on
stories in
subsequent movies because the world has
been told to you
in a game but but this is the thing
though in in
two all of the stuff that you guys say
yes
running around in the mako on its own
right was not was not great but the
thing about it is the fact that they
tried
to allow you to land on a planet i get
it right
the idea the idea
is that rather than expand upon it
rather than expand upon it and
and and fix it right they said we're
cutting it
because people felt it wasn't fun
here so here's one so here this is a
very this is just my opinion
travis is right no facts here but here's
my disappointment in mass effect 2 and i
love mass effect 2 and i love this
series
but my disappointment with mass effect 2
is if you go back to old bioware
old bioware used to do some special
stuff
that wasn't really mainstream i don't
mean this in like i'm cool because i'm
unique and special
they did their own thing and they were
they were unapologetic about it you know
look i'll be honest
kotor is pretty brutal in a lot of ways
like when you're bringing it
up earlier it's hard to play now it is
it's hard to play but i still love it
mass effect has some fundamental control
problems
i still love it right what i see in mass
effect 2
is the start of i'll say the
casualization
of a game series now that ea owns it
because ea's focus is not the same as
bioware's ea's focus is
i want mass market sales at the broadest
possible scale
and these really complex baldur's gate
level type worlds
don't sell as well as the more generic
throne works i really do love the game
but it but they have to simplify the
game mechanics
for a broader audience so that they can
drive the sales numbers
and i think that ultimately hurt the
mass effect experience
from what one was building and starting
with bioware
and two carried a lot of it through and
i still loved it and you just sort of
see though that the peak was at the end
of one and then it just
between two and three it just sort of
fades out because it turned
into a more simplistic game right
designed to appeal to a larger audience
right and i just think of mass effect 2
the reason i'll always put one over two
well there's two reasons
the first one though is because i think
it's the beginning of the
end for something that bioware had
started that was just magical
and it was going a certain way and then
and i don't like i'm not
banging on ea but like i think they folk
their focus is something different
they're not about being a boutique shop
selling a specific story or a specific
vision they're they're about selling
mass-market products and i think it
hurts the game
let me give red because rand's been
patient range today right now
i want to get you because i can't
visually see you when you're talking
right over there i know let's get ready
cause he's been patient
i mean i don't know i i pretty much laid
out exactly why i like mass effect two
over one i understand everything that
bill's saying
uh you know i take a little umbrage at
like the day you know the dating sim
stuff
but i don't know to me i always i always
feel about a good story is about the
characters
and like to me the characters
make mass effect 2 the the better story
in my opinion like spending all that
time with them
learning what makes them tick and their
their fears and their
you know like the i guess
i don't know like i love mass effect one
but to me
when i was thinking about like do i
really want to replay these games
legendary edition right if i'm starting
from the beginning
i always back because of how
horrible mass effect 1 was
to play not the story story's great like
the epic space
opera that they have going for it the
great moments like the reveal of
sovereign
it always comes down to do i want to
replay and spend
30 hours with that horribly dated
combat and it always comes down to it's
like well man if i need to get to my
if i want to play my baby my mass effect
2
i gotta dredge through 30 hours of
horribly paced
combat and i just don't know if i want
to do that because it was that
bad and it was that bad back in 2007
like people just overlooked it because
it was really the first game of its time
it was bioware's new baby it's a space
epic and people were like
oh man the story and the universe and
the dialogue which we didn't
i love the dialogue system and all the
mass effect games right
like it i like not having i don't know
about you guys i don't know how you play
your games but like
when you played kotor and you can see
what exactly you were gonna say
like i don't know about you but i always
skip that because i would read it
and then i was like well i don't need to
hear it right
so when mass effect introduced more like
canned like
left or right but it was just kind of
emotions i was actually involved
listening to what was going on because i
didn't know what was gonna be said
um and that was maybe one of the biggest
things bioware did for me was because
now i was engaged about like what was
being said how it was being said who it
was said to
but for the end of the day for me when
it comes down to which game is better
i just sit here and i think i want to
replay mass effect 2
but i don't want to actually replay mass
effect 1 because of how bad it was
because of the clunky controls because
of the concave controls
why is that a write-off though
sometimes the problem with games is that
the actual game part of it gets in the
way of the part you want and mass effect
1 is the epitome of that it's like
i want to experience it without having
to love it
that's like that's like a big problem
with games is like developers feel like
they have to turn it into
like where's the where's the jenga
where's like the board game part of this
right right and i i think that mass
effect tries a little too hard to do
that
in a lot of different areas whether it's
the exploration with the mako the combat
system a lot of the stuff it's just like
just get this game out of my way so that
i can have my
story and i that is to me would you like
the story better then
like let me ask a different question if
mass effect 1 played exactly the same as
mass effect 2
would that change your favor
i will say this it will bring it more in
line and i will give you guys this
with this trilogy with the legendary
transitioning about to come out
with we're gonna find our real questions
we're gonna find out yeah that's
why i wanted to do it okay okay can i
say one more thing
uh because the dating sim thing has come
up multiple times
i
i'm actually the only person i know who
in all three mass effect games never
romanced
anyone and anytime somebody came up to
me and was like hey commander shepard
you're kind of cute i was like what are
you insane we have worlds
the right decision right not accept your
uh your
advances focus motivation i am i
i am here for the characters the story
i just want to state once again that the
dating sim portions of bioware games is
a staple of all their older games
except for my favorite always reject
i tell you one one thing that's very
strong for me is to pick to piggyback
off of what what bill said
is the fact that when you look at
our feelings on modern day bioware and
whatever influences ea may or may not
have on them
and you look at mass effect 2 like bill
said
it feels like mass effect 2 in a lot of
ways is the harbinger of doom
as much as people love that game it does
begin to introduce things
that in later bioware properties we
become very critical of right uh
you know it is sort of this downward
slope when you look at you know
even looking at you know air quotes game
of the year dragon age inquisition
there were changes that were beginning
there that that were sort of moving away
from what we knew and expected of
bioware
and i think for me it's strongest in
mass effect 2 well the beginnings of it
are strongest in mass effect 2
as something that feels completely
different from what i expected coming
out of one
and so for me it felt like a little bit
of a betrayal like it really did solve
you said you mean for all bioware games
who were strongest in mass effect 2
well the beginnings of it were massive
actually
the same series right yeah
age 2 is a complete departure complete
100 dragon age origins is that i felt a
lot of people felt it it was uh
i think you see the same metamorphosis i
mean yeah
so okay we bill kind of touched on this
a little bit with the whole ea thing
which i i do agree he's 100 percent on
on point out but let's imagine there's
an alternate universe that exists
an ea didn't buy bioware and mike
microsoft game studios published mass
effect 2
in 2010 what does that game look like
then
is it not the mass effect that we know
now is it completely different and more
in line with mass effect one like what
do you think mass effect 2 would have
been
if they never were bought by ea i think
you'd see improved combat with less of a
streamlining of what is the story and
world building aspect i mean if you go
in
and i'm not taking anything away from
mass effect 2 because i mean we've had
our shots i i don't want to i like mass
effect 2.
but if you go in and you're looking if
you don't sir you don't that's that's
actually incorrect
like the codex of mass effect 2 and it
has like a couple of additions
but it's not anything like it was in
mass effect 1. and and the structure of
mass effect 2
is one of the things that i'm really
bothered by and that's just because from
a kind of story standpoint
i don't really like to see the mechanics
and the puppet strings and mass effect 2
is so kind of rigid
in collect the character loyalty mission
collect the character loyalty mission
halfway point collect the character
loyalty mission
go and it's like that can be fine i
describe it as a collection of short
stories
to be mildly derogative to some people
but not very very derogatory
because collections of short stories can
be very very good i don't know if you've
read it yeah
i disagree with you
i don't think hogue's wrong on that but
the thing but like the biggest crux is
we already have bill still though
saying mass effect 2 is a better game
than that yeah
he has mass effect andromeda as the
second greatest mass effect of all time
this is ridiculous
wow
all right now since you're bringing up
evidence you're going to have to give me
the floor for a minute yes
explain yourself okay explain yourself
sir
so to reflect on what i said earlier
is your second greatest mass effect of
all
time and that is this man speaking now
now
explain you'll see why is that if we if
we think about what i've said in this
video why is that yes
let's go which is that i when i play a
role-playing game whether it's a
japanese role-playing game a western
role-playing game bioware bethesda
whomever
i honestly don't care about the
mechanics you guys are having a great
conversation about the gameplay and the
macko and the
clutchy controls and all that and i
understand it i have never cared i
played final fantasy when it was on the
original nintendo and things didn't even
move when you hit the controller hit the
right buttons
i want a good story and what i really
wanted out of mass effect
was a story that was focused on this
kind of exploration
and uh star trekiness going out
exploring brave new worlds and mass
effect 2
went a different direction went into
kind of a a personal story but you know
looking at the underworld and looking at
things that weren't
kind of exposing yourself to a new
galaxy and worlds of possibilities
and mass effect 3 was obviously very
focused on the crisis
the reapers and even though i don't
think they did the pacing very well
since they're constantly under attack
you know it's a different kind of thing
in terms of story
i always wanted what mass effect 1 and
mass effect andromeda presented
as a concept which is this exploration
and going and seeing new things
and finding out new parts of the galaxy
and world building that's what i value
so so a world building
aside are you know one of the worst
technically released games ever the game
that was it literally lives in infamy
for ruining bioware right i mean you're
running around naked and outriders so we
can talk about technique
but this is the game you are a champion
so so so world
building above everything even if the
game is not technically sound
that is what you are championing sir so
i think andromeda got a bit of an
internet wrap on this i don't view it as
extraordinarily problematic when
compared with the bethesda games of the
world
when compared with everything we've seen
in the last 12 months
of patches i had to re-download eternal
for god's sakes
so i mean when we're talking about
technological issues
i didn't really have this again i can't
believe this has happened
no no but i will say this are focused on
something different
and and i think we can all agree on that
because what i'm hearing from the other
side
is that i like what it was focusing on
and i don't blame you for that
but that's not what i wanted out of the
mass effect series we got that space
opera
which you want but if it's technically
broken
i never had a problem
you can't project you could if what he
cares about and
i get that right but technologically
you want to talk about logically and
here's what i always say to people
because people come into my comments or
whatever and say how can you love this
broken thing
and i can only comment on what i
experienced right i mean this is the
thing with reviewers and drama never
broke for me
and dragon never had any significant
issues for me so i i don't know i you
want me to take into account like
everybody else's experiences cog
and i understand that and i will i will
couch it with i understand a lot of
people have had issues with it
right i didn't personally so i can't
judge it on that right okay
let's forget the bugs for a moment with
andromeda it is
the one mass effect game that plays the
best when it comes to combat
it's combat is better than the other
three games
it has the worst story it has
two protagonists the writer twins that
do not compare the shepherd
shepard's toenail is more impressive
than these two twins
never actually really like i mean we can
get into that if you will oh my god
y'all
and i literally have an article on my
site that says i'm worried about mass
effect
there you go no no you got a crew in
andromeda
that's worse than the crew in mass
effect three yeah
can't even name all the characters in
the crew
because they are so bland and i don't
remember anything i don't like
anybody that's effect three to be fair i
don't there's the guy that's working out
different people appreciate different
aspects of these games
so you know rand has talked about the uh
the personal relationship building of
mass effect 2 which is arguably one of
its greatest strengths right
absolutely and if you value that in your
games in your rpgs whatever it may be
then you're going to hold that on a
higher pedestal than someone who may
value something else so i think hogue
i'm not
i'm not with him on the internet he's
not winning no i just i want to ask the
mass effect one panel
you know mayna so solve do you feel mass
effect andromeda is the second greatest
at mass effect of all time
you know okay
do you feel that mass effect andromeda
is the second best f
no that's you know they actually are you
real still are you implying
second best mass effect i picked mass
effect
without any consultation with anybody
else who was going to be on
this side of the panel so i can't speak
to any other opinions that those
individuals
i rest my case i was going to say bill
was my spirit animal and what what shirt
are you wearing lord cognito of course
yours
[Laughter]
that's a good pull from you and i
understand you know it's one of those
things where
i think objectively andromeda is
obviously the one that is most
castigated and has the most issues
i like here's one of the things that i
think is interesting because i heard
this on a couple of directions from the
panel
i think the mass effect one team to some
extent and i want to speak for all of
them because they're distancing
themselves from me
no that mass effect one had some
problems and you i think rightly pointed
them out in terms of the barren planets
and the macro and everything
but there is an ambition in mass effect
1 a reach
in mass effect 1. that is collapsed a
bit in mass effect 2.
and you know one of the things i like
about andromeda and i like about indie
games and i like about
things that are failures out on the
market is that reach that exceeds the
grass i like to support that ambition
i liked that bioware was trying to make
a new galaxy
and go out there and build something and
not collapsing in on itself like a dying
star which is what i'm afraid of from
that
all right let me go for me i put in
drummond on his space which says oh
they're they're gonna try to do
something new
and maybe i give it a little bit more
credit than it deserves because i love
this one okay as long as you admit that
okay
okay you know what i i still put it
second i do
but i do like to see people try for
greatness
you like you like what you like you know
what i'm saying um i will i will have a
counter to mr hogue i feel like i'm
always kind of
is like i feel you uh you basically said
that you like mass effect 1 because
you like um the reach right like
compared to two right uh was basically
yeah well the world building the story
building mission yeah right i actually
feel that
doing a more personal story is harder
a galactic story because in a galactic
story you can
you can sort of be more vague you don't
really have to flesh
everything out but if you're doing 12
individual
personal stories and they're not good
because they have to really
hammer home the emotions then that game
overall
is going to fail right so i actually
think mass effect 2
is the um what's the word i'm looking
for here um
ambitious ambitious it's more ambitious
it's a bigger it's a it's a bigger reach
than mass effect one
simply because if you don't nail the
stories
then the game overall is going to fail
i love the way you phrase that i think
you hit for me the biggest
gap with two when i talked about how it
became more casual
i loved this the the core storyline of
me1 i think is one of the better story
lines in games
my pro and i actually agree with you
like the relationship those which i make
fun of it like the relationship building
was the heart of me too
my challenge with the me2 overarching
story though
was it took all sense of urgency out of
the main storyline so to so it's like
here's this very
tight story in me1 from start to finish
and now it's here's the collection of 12
short stories
that are all well done but they then
lost this
overarching thread i never really felt
any pressure to get this done to get to
that final mission in me2
the same way i felt driven in me1
to make progress in the story and so i
completely respect that
if you love that character creation part
of two
i could see why you would consider it a
better game for me though
the focus on doing that well which they
did i think
broke then the overarching story of why
you were really caring about putting
that crew together in the first place
right now i i get i get the urgency
thing because
it's also kind of an issue in three like
oh the reapers are here and they're
attacking but
let's go romance let's go these guys
where it's like hey the collectors are
the human species but you know what i
gotta go see miranda and i gotta
i gotta do her like i get that and that
is that is like you know a problem that
some people do have with this i
i i kind of disagree for a moment and i
i i respect bill's opinion here but i
disagree
for the fact that you can choose to say
i
i ain't got time for that yeah
you get you get out of that the end
result
which you put into it so like if uh um
if
miranda says hey look they they my
sister is in trouble
i hit her from my father i need to get
her out of there and you're just like
yo you trying to save the universe
though what are you doing
no ain't got time for that right now you
don't get her loyalty
later on that pays but the cost of that
can cost you if you have that approach
if you feel like
all this stuff is i'm all your personal
problems i don't know why y'all coming
to me for this i'm the captain
i'm the commander this is a mission to
do let's do this mission
and you will get the result of that in
the in how you finish the game you can
make the best choices put the best
people in the right positions
hatali take the vents hey hey uh gareth
hold the door but if you don't have
their loyalty you lose lives it's like
there is a cost to it and so
i felt that in my a gazillion
playthroughs
of these games in mass effect 2 i'm
always looking at like
when to do us a loyalty mission when to
take care of it
i always do jack jack's loyalty mission
first
because i know that i can get miranda's
loyalty later right
it's how you have to do it and in the in
the pressure and the tension and
and the urgency i felt the urgency
when the collectors took my crew yeah
remember when they bought the ship
yeah yeah and you have you have a
maximum of
one or two missions that you can do
before that crew gets liquidated and you
lose them
but but there's one thing that's the one
story aspect there that kind of bugged
me out
when you leave the normandy to sort of
go i
don't even tell you where you go you
just you leave it
unprotected and joker's there like that
was a story
piece of the story that to me was was
bonkers for me you leave it joker's the
only person left on that ship
and there's no way they can defend
themselves and then you come back
and then you blame joker for letting
everybody get liquidated i'm just like
what happened
what they didn't blame joker they
absolutely blamed jokes they didn't
blame
john miranda miranda blames
everybody for everything that's trapped
and then sure does the brand i would
also i would also like to push back
against the whole like urgency thing and
i think it actually opens it up to
like a broader conversation about mass
effect and like the different stories it
tells depending on how you play it but
for me i'm like a hardcore paragon uh
shepherd so for me the story of mass
effect is that like
the things that you think wouldn't be
urgent or important are all that matters
and like the human part of like
these these people you're making friends
with is actually
what saves you in the end right because
if you avoid those loyalty quests then
you actually could fail the mission or
everyone could die and that sort of
thing and so these
these you know non-urgent little side
quests are actually the only thing that
matters and i think that's the story
that mass effect tries to tell is that
like
the small details and the human parts of
the world are really
all that matters in this galaxy that
kind of decorates itself with
war and politics and strife and all that
and and you know you can kind of throw
that to the wind with the uh
renegade fault the renegade path and i
think it tells a very different story
but
it it we all have different personal
connections to this and to me it's like
hey one one krogan who was able to be
convinced
that you know they should give other
people a chance that is actually what
made the difference
and allowed these people to survive and
so i i think i think
i think it's a little pessimistic to
just say like oh yeah and these stories
are side quests and they don't matter
like that's the story of mass effect man
like that's what this game is about to
me
but that's a wildly different direction
than it is at the end of the mass effect
1. see i read
the the problem with urgency not as
within mass effect 2 i think you've
made very good arguments why picking
which loyalty mission to choose
is urgent and that actually changing
people's minds is effective for that
story
on the macro basis in the story of a
trilogy
mass effect 2 still neatly kind of
slides out of everything if you want it
to
because mass effect 1 goes right to the
reapers on the doorstep and mass effect
3 starts with them arriving
so you have this kind of momentum going
then you have this stall
which we can enjoy and we can enjoy the
stories that it tells
but in terms of actually telling a
trilogy it's a it's a weird bit of
pacing
when one goes so neatly with three and
two is kind of we're gonna
talk about characters for an entire game
are we saying
how about that because i think two does
something in the larger story but
yeah ho ho would we know that
lead writer drew carpenter who wrote
knights of the old republic and
and baldur's gate and he's the lead
writer for mass effect one and two
was not the lead writer for mass effect
3 because the way he wanted to end the
series
wasn't what casey hudson wanted to do
that's that's the t
right so so if he's not the guy
that finishes the story we know some of
the subplots
that are in uh look like lightly touched
on in one
or into like tally's entire loyalty
mission
where she's like they got that son
that's like going supernova
why is this happening that all was
supposed to tie into why the reapers
were doing what they were doing from the
very start
if we i think do you think it's still
okay to say well this doesn't really tie
into the trilogy well when the trilogy
when those two games were made the
trilogy didn't end the way the lead
writer has set things up
from the very start yeah i mean i think
mass effect had problems but i still
think
even even with drew k and everybody else
going into mass effect 2 it was just a
really interesting choice the one that i
don't agree with obviously
when you go from the end of mass effect
1 and you're delivered something
i think which is pretty significantly
different from what the end of one
implies
two is going to be um and so i do think
you get this kind of
skid stop into okay i guess we're gonna
go and go to different people's planets
and talk about sisters and cerberus and
whatever
um and i think that that's fine but
it's not the same type of story as mass
effect 1 and clearly you know in some
respects the mass effect 2 team
prefers that kind of story uh the the
the smaller more personal stories i
think that's fine
uh but to me mass effect one i agree
with bill
is one of the better stories told in
video games i mean it's it's really one
of the legendary kind of runs for
bioware because they got
jade empire and kotor and mass effect
and dragon age origins
which i think is is them at the height
of their modern bioware powers
and i think that that's a very effective
story and then
i i don't so i don't want to
you know i don't want to downgrade the
the the loyalty missions and the
character beats i
absolutely think that they are better
characters than in either one or three
and i think that they are effectively
told i don't see them as the pinnacle of
greatness in terms of storytelling
as i do with kind of the overall thrust
of realistically
mass effect 1 and dragon age origins
which are kind of being developed
simultaneously
at bioware at the same time that those
really work well in terms of pacing and
plot and combination
and and getting to an ending that that
that feels great where
that just never worked for me on mass
effect 2 even though in the
moment-to-moment game play
um i enjoyed kind of each short story in
each character
uh as much as anything else he's back
he's back he's in the bushes oh
cool i think i think slo-mo's point
though was that like
two gets a bad rep for sorry sorry
two gets a bad rep for like the sins of
three right like
it's oh it's disconnected from one and
three but like it could have been
way more like the whole dark matter
subplot that was introduced into they
got thrown away like
it could have been it could have been
hugely consequential to the arc and i
think
part of the reason it feels out of place
is because of the change in three
not because of anything that two did so
i i mean i think mass effect has a
problem as a series
overall because like two starts and it
kind of goes in a weird direction and
three
you know you the i and i'm sorry i
forget the name of the stupid deus ex
machina thing that's going to kill all
the reapers
uh but it appears out of nowhere and oh
now we got to fix the deus ex machina i
mean it's
it's a it's got some weird transitions
as a series while still telling some
good stories inside of it
right absolutely steve get your point
out sure i got i got two points
uh number one i think you gotta look at
the story as an overhaul when we compare
this to something like star wars you
gotta understand that star wars was
written
all three movies at the same time that's
why things are so interlocked
uh you have the characters you have the
motivations you have the proper setup
that you need to tell
this single story that takes place in
the entire galaxy
mass effect did not have that they
didn't sit there playing out three games
consecutively how things were going to
intertwine
so directly with the you know
presumption of
dlc and all that other stuff so you
didn't have that
you know and i think that's the problem
is that you also had this preconceived
notion that you wanted the end of mass
effect 3 to be
your head everyone had their own
perception of how it was going to end
and it's like it's like whenever you see
someone online
they're going to throw out oh here's my
prediction right one division man
everyone had their prediction no it's
gonna be mephisto it was never mephisto
and now everyone's upset that because
they didn't get they didn't get to be
the guy who called it you know
that's the problem uh so that when we
look at mass effect as a whole
and you look at the story you kind of
have to take it how it is
like travis said that's the story and
you're just
the player your only other choice is to
not play
that's it that's that's my first point
second point uh in an outside scale of
creative respect um
why if i don't save miranda's sister
uh does he just give up
but that's the thing is that like i
think that when i look at mass effect 2
um some parts just kind of make me go i
wonder why that was done
on this creative side was everything
else fine everything was fine in both
games
but i tend to look at the creative side
of things and why they are done a
specific way and i get
why they did it that way i just i wish
it was a little bit more
concise i think what again we're kind of
getting beating the same points over and
i think what's happening here again
is this whole overarching thought about
you know the
overarching space opera right and what
you guys love about you know
the old school bioware the ambition
right
and we admit like it definitely you know
set the stage for something that appears
to be great and then where the
disconnect between
all groups scenes as soon as mass effect
2 starts
you know you guys wanted a more
expansion on that
where you got this more condensed
personal story with specific characters
and stuff like that the only thing i'll
push back again
you know i feel when you you look at
worlds like um
omega and you look at or like i said
tachanka
and you really get in that like omega to
me was just like seedy underworld
bling you know what i'm saying yeah you
know it just
to me it gave me the travis said it best
like
i love mass effect one but i wanted to
get back into the story and the game
kept getting in the way
and i just i just wanted to this story's
so cool sarin is cool we give it up
sovereign
dope you know saying but it was just one
of those things so then when when two
hits it just hits the ground running
the pacing i feel is arguably way better
because it's like
it's just bam bam bam concise now i hear
your argument on
you know as far as you know do your
romance while something else is going on
fair enough that that's it that's the
game being a game you know saying and i
won't push back too much on that
but i just that and i never forget again
i want to reiterate
the xenophage thing because i was a big
krogan fan i'm a big rex fan you get
grunt
right he's got to go through his kind of
like trial of passage thing as a kroger
whatever
and to me to have him and
more than this relationship where you
know this race
really tried to neuter another race
you know i said because they were too
much you know what i'm saying i got you
though
and um at the end of the day it's like
yeah
i'm sorry i gotta get this on screen but
yes at the end of the day that and then
again the more
expansion on the tally character you
know what i mean again with with the
quarians and and the guests fighting
this this enemy and then
you get legion who's this quote-unquote
anomaly right
and now could really enter your crew and
i just again i just
it's personal preference at that point
right this is this is subjective you
know by the end of the day i just felt
i had such a connection with this cat
even the ship which was edie
right was this portable ai that you
could you know bring it to the joy so
again
i get it i want it i know we're beating
these points to death but i want to ask
this
question for the last thing before we
move on which is
now the legendary is coming right now
that
you know mass effect one is going to get
these improvements
right now i want to i want to start on
mass effect 2 team
and we got to be honest if
mass effect 2 i mean mass effect 1 he
gets all these opponents
and it plays better and it and it the
stuff that we hate
about the it's original like i'm
starting with you travis like
will it get closer to you or potentially
to get the title in your eyes
after that yeah i'm certainly open to it
actually
um the fact that i like mass effect 2
over mass effect 1 is a bit
like not on brand for me like i tend to
like the nerdier rpg games like my
favorite elder scrolls game is elder
scrolls three morrowind which like
most people when they try to play that
game yeah most people when they try to
play that game today they're like what
the heck is this this is so clunky but
it's still the best
it's still the best yep so i i will
agree with you but
to me that's because the the the merits
of more when the virtues sort of
outweigh the the clunkiness and
mass effect one it i i think also does
that like it's not like it's a bad game
because
it's so clunky but mass effect 2
takes away the clunkiness without losing
really that much of what made mass
effect one great in my opinion
whereas you know if you go to oblivion
and skyrim you lose a lot of kind of the
the stuff that was in more one in my
opinion so
i i just think that it's not that much
of a downslope so i'm certainly open to
mass effect
becoming like my favorite mass effect
game i honestly love all of the mass
effect games even andromeda honestly
like
it's not the it's not as good as the
original trilogy but like
is it like a terrible game i i actually
agree with hogue like i think the
internet's way harsh on
on andromeda for unfairly
there are bad games like i've played
them i've
i reviewed them
andromeda i will tell you i will play
dramatic ten times over some of the
games i've had to play
uh the reviews so when you play destiny
you know what a bad game is
i went to right there i love that my man
first guy to admit i say all the time on
fire team chat it's one of my favorite
it's one of the best and 10 of the worst
games i've ever played that's destiny
um so uh yeah i have plenty of problems
with that game but yeah i i
i'm interested to see how it changes i
from what my my initial thoughts are is
that it doesn't seem like the changes
are
that extreme it seems like they were a
little afraid of of upsetting the hogs
of the world
so uh if if hope doesn't care about the
mechanics they could change all they
want
code is good you just want the world
building okay well then that's fine yeah
incredible
i think some i think some people were
attached to the the
the not so good um gameplay stuff so
um because it gives you more freedom at
the cost of you know it being
compelling yeah hey hey i'm just saying
that
that is one thing so yeah my answer is i
i have no idea i'm open to it i hope
i hope that it's good but uh you know at
the the worst case scenario is i'll at
least get to smile when i walk into
my base and that guy shouts i will
destroy you
i might enter
steve's got to leave dude can he just
say his piece yeah steve could go yes
yeah please do all right so uh i want to
say thank you very much
uh for having me around i appreciate
this is a great talk
uh you know everyone's really passionate
about
the game and i think that speaks levels
because
in the end it does does it really matter
no it doesn't but the fact is that we
all
can have this conversation and have it
be entertaining
and uh it's just it's amazing i greatly
appreciate it and i
am looking forward as the person
reviewing this series
i am i am looking forward to
taking everything we've talked about
here
thank you very much for having me i'll
see you guys around your brother
all right very fun take care man have a
go
let's finish up with mass effect 2 team
um again this is a question
which would be with the improvements
legendary edition
is there a chance that it could take the
title from below
i i must say probably no and this is why
i in my ranking of mass effect games i
have mass effect 2
mass effect 3 and then mass effect 1.
and then the drama that doesn't exist
so so i usually i i can see
if they i i've read through the game
like i did videos on it the gameplay
improvements the changes they did to one
to get it more in line with two and
three
if they really hit it and they really
take care of it really well
i think it will probably leap frog three
okay but be
in between uh okay
i see uh miranda lawson aka or forte
just jump back in
uh are you there sir miss okay yeah i'm
here
because we're getting into the
conclusion for the two team and then
we'll let the one team conclude
um again with the legendary edition on
on the rise
do you think that could push mass effect
one ahead of our beloved mass effect 2
no chances had
because okay are they are they i mean
they're taking walls down in buildings
and stuff and they're they're making the
game play more like mass effect 2 which
which depends on how you feel about
gameplay and stuff that's a great thing
but they're not really doing anything to
make the story any different
i mean mass effect 2 is still going to
be to me
the superior story and the spirit
superior
experience that you're going to get in
the game now is it going to bring it
more
closer in line to that i like i'm pretty
much you know
i'm pretty much like uh i'm pretty much
like slow-mo
i think over three two i think it could
jump over three because i think three
was just to track me to get to the end
i enjoyed three i enjoyed um
the experiences i had in there i think
there were a lot of memorable
experiences in there but i thought there
was a lot of numeral
experiences inside of one i just think
when you stack two versus one
there's just so many different things
that stood out to me
that i remember than i would ever even
care to remember that happened in mass
effect one
but the gameplay is definitely gonna be
something that's gonna
step that game up to being something
that a lot of people are
gonna enjoy more than ever i think that
i think for most people
the reason they're buying the mass
effect legendary edition is because
of one it's not because we know two is
going to be great but we want to see
what one
feels and plays like if it was done the
way that mass effect 2 was done and
that's a testament to
this game is literally going to be
selling for 60 bucks because everybody
wants to see what this first one feels
like now
so i don't think it could be better it
could be
the one a to the to the to the top spot
but you know but that's going to be
different for every person that picks up
the game
fair enough ran out final question mass
effect 2t
do you think with the legendary edition
that mass effect 1 could have the title
over your beloved mass effect 2
i mean i think i i pretty much laid out
why mass effect 2 is better for me
and that's the story and the stuff so uh
i would say no
uh but it would you know like i'd want
to replay mass effect one
because i want the gameplay to be better
and uh i'm just gonna be messy just for
a second because
i normally don't do this and i already
know the responses to shut it down so i
already know about bill and hulk are
going to respond to this but let's not
forget the fact okay that when ea sold
mass effect 2
on the ps3 for the first time there was
no mass effect 1 in fact
all the choices from the beloved mass
effect 1 were in a comic book form that
were
done in three minutes so ea was
basically telling people you don't need
to play mass effect one to enjoy this
mass effect here i mean
oh i know how the contracts work right i
i know the response i know exactly how
it
works
i know you would know and so would bill
but i'm just saying i forget
that they're like yeah mass effect one
doesn't matter here's two enjoy
and did it hurt the experience at all no
no i got y'all messing around
microsoft worth noting that microsoft of
course owned the publishing rights at
the time
so it's fine no doubt look great
exclusive for them they should have
bought buyers
but it but it was it was a great uh i
agree it was nice talking to everybody
no
doubt uh everybody's passionate about
mass effect which is amazing it's one of
my favorite uh
game series of all time so what's better
than talking games
exactly let's conclude with the mass
effect 1t so i've brought a strong team
to the
to the plate love this discussion man
what are you guys most excited about man
as we conclude with the legendary
edition man mass effect one team
well can i can i conclude by responding
please please can i conclude
i'm going to play a different story
because if you want to make let like
i love the whole series i'm excited to
play the new the remake i mean i
really am excited for it um but here's
what i'm going to say
mass effect 1 has an outsized impact
on what we're doing today in the gaming
space and here's what i mean by that
we're going to go back a number of years
to an e3
where microsoft got up on stage when i
was fired then
and announced i was back coming to the
to the console
which at the time very few people
thought any value
[Applause]
this is his job it turned
out that mass effect one of our you know
a good partner willing to step up on
stage
because back then nobody was like why
are you doing this this is dumb we don't
want you to bring games forward
it led to that whole library of 360 and
xbox original titles on
on the xbox one now playable on the xbox
series
[Applause]
a whole bunch of enhancements on xbox
one x
now even broader with auto hdr
i love it i love it it was great no
doubt let's get aids man
the legends season gaming we've been
fighting and beefing for weeks oh
man this has been hilarious um in all
seriousness let me show you
what i was reading this is not a joke i
went this morning because i keep gaming
magazines because i'm a weirdo
this is this is may 2011.
and mass effect 3 was getting ready to
come out and i was looking for quotes
where they talk about fixing stuff from
mass effect 2.
i could actually read some of them from
casey hudson and the lead uh director if
you like but you know
we'll save it for another one
[Laughter]
but you know like yeah we we agree with
our fans that we went too far in the
other direction
it's fine it's fine we can we can leave
it alone i mean we doing that i can read
quotes from a few weeks ago
a few weeks ago
and do you disagree that those things
david silverman
the casey guys who made one into the
casing that came with the uh red blue or
red ending let's take his uh opinion
right anyway hey there you go no doubt
look get your balls
get your yeah no i think uh no in all
seriousness this has been hilarious
um i i agree i love this series um
i i still love to don't don't get me
wrong i think uh and i actually really
enjoyed three i didn't even have that
big of a problem with three's ending um
only because you know i'm one of those
people where it's like
unless it really really turns me off um
okay that's what the creators wanted to
do with it so be it you know it wasn't
my favorite thing in the world but
whatever um man i'm telling you my
throat
um i think all the points especially
that um
uh my my team here talked about about
being grander in scope and kind of that
classic
dna if you will from the bioware of old
the knights of the old republic that's
why i brought it up dragon age origins
is a great example
amazing game and i just felt like this
was the sci-fi
epic from that dna you know what i mean
mass effect 1 did that for me and i
still feel as we've talked about i still
feel as a story arc
from beginning to end within the game it
has the best
it has the best story and to me we
talked about people
liking different things within their
games no doubt the relationship building
in two is is all i really like
i mean i love it but as an
overall story arc i feel that once
better and i think i'm just one of those
it's funny travis you brought more a win
because i'm the same i think more wins
the best elder scrolls game
i i didn't really even care for oblivion
that much uh
skyrim is good but more it just you know
it's not the same and your point
is actually a great analogy because when
you go back and play more win now
there's a lot of mechanics in that game
that are just like holy [ __ ] this is
dated right
you know i mean there just is but
as an overall game and what it presents
i still feel it's the best night that's
what it is for mass effect 1 for me i'm
just that
i am old school i love these old school
rpgs
i just i love these things even if
they're clunky a little bit like
i said it's like i'm good no no
and it is right i mean i don't think any
of us are denying that but that doesn't
detract from it enough yeah i know it
it's it's just personal
uh preference at that point yeah right
it's whatever you weigh more right and
which is the same
aspect of this yeah and so that's it for
me
in all seriousness like i said this has
been great uh i know we're still gonna
continue to joke about this
i'm so excited for next week um because
i can't wait for all of us and the
collective
you know audience that we all talk to to
go back and start playing these games
ago and and really see how it feels to
go back through them with these updates
uh it's gonna be a lot of fun
it's gonna be awesome hulk crossfire
today
oh you know he left for half the show i
don't know if you know that
it's all right andromeda for a little
while
for half of the show with your back this
is uh this is like the day job here
actually i'm getting i'm getting the
work week
vibes in here you guys would make
excellent opposing counsel
um and as always i'm always thankful to
be a part of these conversations i
cannot think of a better way to spend
two hours on a saturday than talking
with all you
about awesome video games both of which
mass effect 1 and mass effect 2
are you asked the question you know am i
looking forward to
the legendary edition i have to tell you
i'm all in favor of the mechanics
improving and what they talk about there
i'm mildly terrified of what they did to
mass effect 1 in terms of that yeah um
you know i put up some tweets and some
social media things and i can't judge
these things until i play it
but they've tried to improve things like
lighting
that really matters to mood um and there
was a very kind of dramatic we've used
the word space opera here
a lot that was over the top you know
when
you first see sovereign it's like a
freaking not normal
black cloud and red lightning and
everything else and
the images that they've shown from the
legendary edition is
kind of a soft sunset like i have a i
have a tweet that i put out that's like
well now sovereign looks for
who nice walks on the beach ice cream
sundaes
and and it's it'll be interesting
because i want it to be great
i i love mass effect um and mass effect
1 was special to me i think that's right
as i've said as part of this
in their wheelhouse for when they were
really firing on all cylinders at least
their modern form
post balder's gate and that kind of
thing um and so i'm interested in
playing it
um i'm looking forward to it uh i
who knows maybe the rest of the mass
effect trilogy will get elevated
one enough i i don't know two might come
from the bottom
yeah but no i think i i think it's it's
interesting
i do also note talking about backwards
compatibility and awesome things that
microsoft is doing
that obviously the mass effect series
notably omitted from all of the many
games that are getting
fps boosts and other benefits from the
microsoft side of things
the corporate world we live in
the lawyer i get everything that's
happening there but i can't help but
look at it and say oh yay
i i got you i know you want your 60. i
understand
i understand and i am still looking
forward it to it in any event and again
you know thanks for having me players
can be a bit much and i always
appreciate it i appreciate you brother
one thing about you you stand on your
square regardless to what you stand on
yourself
i love that what i believe that's what
you believe i
talk that talk that's what i'm talking
about i saw
my brother it was it was very intense
it's very intentional i like you for a
lot of
funny thing is like i talked about the
beginning how how we used to do this
back in the day it was funny because a
lot of this back in the day
happened at cognito's house right so you
could imagine
two young young guys
so if you get into the argument with the
owner of the home
i was the host i was still the host
yeah it was taking your ball and going
home i got kicked out of that house
[Laughter]
but it speaks to the passion we have for
these games and specifically
mass effect i love mass effect in its
entirety
100 percent even the step child
andromeda forward
for what it tried to do what did you do
for whatever it tried to do but
but for me the first one is so special
because of
the scope that they were trying to
achieve and in part
really did achieve for me um
when i think to the future and i think
about
the things we the improvements we've
seen in sort of world building
characterization when you look at like
the witcher 3
and and the hopes and dreams that we
have for what
for me fulfill what i expected mass
effect
to be from the very beginning and this
is strange for me to say
because i am the dude that really does
believe that
characterization and interpersonal
relationships do
make the crux of the best for the most
part the
overarching stories a lot of times just
uh
just give you the through line to get
through but but but at the end of the
day
the stories and and that you come up
with with the in the character
characters you end up loving are the
ones that really resonate and stay with
you
um i just thought that two
did that part so well at the exclusion
of the other stuff that i loved and won
and i didn't understand why um
but that said i played through it twice
i love it
i even love three i i i'm fine with the
ending
um i'm never opposed to
um a developer sticking to their guns
when they get when they tell you this is
our story this is what it is
we're gonna stick to our guns and i i
didn't necessarily like what they did at
the end of three and sort of changing
stuff
but again i'm most excited to see new
people
next week possibly be motivated to pick
up this game
and that have never seen it never played
it and
fall in love with it the way we did now
more nearly 15 years ago exactly
um and i hope that happens i really do
and i'll wrap it up
yeah absolutely and that that's
literally my same point that i was going
to say you know again tremendous to me
thank everybody for coming through this
this is fire this is this is a lot of
fun a lot of passion
a lot of heat you know and uh it was fun
and like i said you know we all set off
points at nauseam
it's going to be great to see this uh
legendary edition you know i'm saying
how everything changes in that regard
obviously two is very special to me very
special um
just what a tremendous ride and i'll
never forget it was like it was just
like my heart was racing every single
part to see what was gonna happen
and the relationships but like you said
so i think to me it always comes down to
with this legendary edition you know how
this new generation of gamers who's
never
experienced this who's never seen any of
it
right how are they going to embrace and
then what's their take
you know do they lean mass effect 1 they
say oh yeah mass effect 2 we get
i'm very curious i spoke to undead
addict is one of them you know
this new generation to see how they
absorb this belonging
is gonna be fun to see man so i'm gonna
be funny when they all pick three
yeah you know we'll see
honestly they might they might they
might 100 percent they don't have the
nostalgia and the the
that old love they're coming in and
getting it all
at once exactly and when you play it all
at once
you may think three had the best
mechanics the ending
yeah i i do i do really wish that they
made the decision
to upgrade the engine they made the
decision to keep it all on unreal engine
3 which
you know like there's a lot of people
who will look at it and say
even though they did make visual
improvements it still looks dated you
see the
the human features oh i think the the
aliens look much much better if you look
at like thane
things like that harris looks amazing
but then you see
like uh captain anderson just like oh
you know
[Laughter]
yeah yeah the uncanny valley and i i
really wish they could have because
if they would have did a full-on remake
on like unreal engine 5
or something like that or god forbid
frostbite engine but like
if they were they did something like
that it would have been coming out
right like years later but right before
mass effect 4.
and think about that kind of impact they
could have been introducing a whole new
generations into the series and then
here
here's the brand new part of it right
here and that would have been
like i think that probably would have
been better for bioware but
i'm sure they can sell it to us again
yeah
i'm sure they will absolutely this
concludes
the debate fantastic gentlemen good work
all solved we got super chats but
we have some super chat i want to hold
everyone hostage anyone who has to leave
please
again it was an absolute pleasure whole
grand outdoor thank you gentlemen
miranda lawson aka forte
agitator steve my man the legend
bill stillwell on vr i love the n7 shirt
by the way that was great
and of course my man you know what i'm
saying reasonable minds can't disagree
you know we can't
no no so we got to just read these super
chats and did everyone hey hey hey uh
what's up i do have to go i got that
yeah i got at some point
thanks again gentlemen again pleasure
to do this with you guys it's been a lot
of fun and i just want to
before i leave i think we all know which
one's the best
as he walks
we have philip carlisle two dollar super
chat salute to you all by the way me3 is
me3 though beautiful
me3 and the man cunningham the five
dollar super chat
mass effect was the first story
character driven space rpg in the video
game
mass effect 2 streamlined the rpg
elements out of it and became a space
shooter
me1 let me uh delete his accent
then we have sarco with the five dollar
super chat i heard from a guy who knows
a guy who did time with a guy that said
it was the anthem team that primarily
worked on mass effect 2.
just
then we have philip carla once again two
dollars super chat great discussion
about emmy
but me3 one of the best i mean three
um then we're the same guy though i know
that we have a double representative fat
boy horror
with the five pound super chat yeah mass
effect one is bomb and had the best
protagonist
then we have lucious augustus five
dollars in the chat
sarin was just a brainwashed xenophobe
that was tight that his proud people had
problems beating the humans in the first
contact war
yeah yep agreed
five dollar super chat um the character
development and interaction suffered in
mass effect 2
due to the transition to the playstation
watered down story story is superior in
what
were there stories that came out about
that getting it on both consoles or
something like that i don't recall
then we have bra with the two dollars
super chat martin scene is the elusive
man emmy to the goat
yeah we didn't talk about boys
okay that check was too fat they could
have built out the world if they hadn't
spent
more time
[Laughter]
gaming addict with the two dollar super
chat mass effect two people looking
spooky
yes that is correct and we have lucious
augustus two dollar super chat shadow
broker dlc is why me2 is the goat yes
correct that is why every two would
let me put this additive thing to get me
over the hump
then the man cunningham once again with
five dollars effect one money okay
massive big one is the star trek of
games and mass effect 2 went star wars
less story driven more actiony nothing
wrong with it but i'll take
mass effect 1. then we have gerald's mac
five dollars liking star wars track over
star wars i judge you
he's being judged uh gerald mc5 dollar
super chat i wonder if the mass effect
one team would like mass effect one
today if it came out and played the same
i told him yes and chad already
probably there we have lord kaibatsu
with the two dollar super chat all hell
cog
aka lord gaslight i had to get back i
had to get him i had my
i was preaching everyone
you want to see hope being objective
then we have philly eagle 5 super chat
hella fun chat debate
three one andromeda and two with this
in that order wow two was blanding me to
each their own though to each their own
for sure then we have gaming times
patrick five dollar super chat
ea needs to cut iop a check because if i
buy mass effect legendary edition day
one
is because of this i'll bring the
memories back
thank you so much let me see and we have
[Laughter]
y'all need to do this more great show
yeah this this is really
this goes to the core of who we are
growing up like it's
always all about stuff it was part of
our culture yeah 100
then we have gaming times patrick once
again two dollar super chat so
when is the best final fantasy
everybody enjoy yo actually aims you got
uh season gaming going on earlier man
telling people what's going on with you
man before we head out
oh yeah yeah seasongaming.com you can
find everything we do there
we had our we do a weekly podcast live
saturdays at noon central so that
episode from today was up in fact we had
hector on oh yes
yes from lords uh oh my god man mo yeah
there was an epic rant in the middle of
our show today so i'll clip that put it
on twitter
but yeah man you can find me on uh
twitter just sayings there's not many
ainslies out there so
i'm easy to find and um seasongaming.com
thank you all for the support
um yeah appreciate the shout out guys no
doubt you already know let's get the man
with the
million rand outdoor my bro xbox 2 was
yesterday what else is going on man
yeah uh yeah not much man i uh just
waiting
uh for mass effect legendary edition
next week currently playing resident
evil village oh it's good isn't it
yeah i think i'm only a couple hours in
but
one of the best looking games out there
uh finished return last week
which was a lot of fun yeah uh but yeah
thanks for having me on gun [ __ ]
it's always it's always good to be back
around the lord
collection it's funny because ain't you
guy
you should have heard about it he was
worried about
i was worried about me because i i i'm
too respectful to people
messy stuff and you did you did
you did uh let your feelings known um in
a very eloquent matter
thai guy travis the legend himself
mcclunky
himself mcclunky my man why are you
making fun of me one again man
[Laughter]
what's going on man yeah they were they
were worried about me
being the opposite of randall thor and
being way too mean yes
i told him down yeah they were like hey
don't like don't make anybody cry and i
was like that's what i do
don't worry yeah you can
uh yeah you can find me on twitter at
thai guy travis and you can read my
articles on ign.com
we just did a exclusive preview of an
upcoming uh remaster of an old
classic game uh alex kidd in miracle
world yeah
yeah the older people here my life that
game looks beautiful
yeah so i got to play through that game
and yeah i got to
got to write some thoughts on that and
then i'm also reviewing the uh
the new kind of like a payday robbery
game called hood
outlaws yeah that one yeah
uh so i'll have that review up this week
if you want to read it on ign.com
brother
always a pleasure man i love the passion
you always bring smoke as always
and of course one of my good friends in
the industry the legend of backup
the legend of project xcloud and now
the new soon-to-be legend facebook via
oculus quest 2
my man the legend bill stillwell man
absolute pleasure wait what you got
going on man
uh thanks for having me on i always
appreciate the opportunity to do this
because as someone who's not a public
figure
uh i don't get to i'm not a professional
talker like the rest of you um
but uh it was it was great to be here um
like you said i you know for those who
don't know i did leave xbox i went over
to
work on oculus i've been there now for a
while and uh because i am a believer in
the vr future i'm trying to convert all
of you
very slowly um i know you do you gotta
there there is oh there you go uh
there's so much that's there
um and and we talked about what the
reason i did it and what i loved about
this is we talked about how emotional
games can be
how they resonate and when you move into
vr the level that it takes in the
immersion
um i still think half-life alex may be
one of the best happenings
you have a whole different discussion
about that later you were telling me
about uh hellblade in vr
last week hellblade so i like how blade
of vr hellblade and vr
or i like hellblade hellblade and vr is
a whole new level
yeah um and i think it's it's one of
those like uh
for what it's worth vr a few years ago
it kind of ruined the industry i think
because everybody tried out cardboard
and
and youtube 360 and what the heck is
this and now
they don't realize how far it's come in
just the last couple of years but
half-life alex made me a believer for
100
yeah yeah that's actually what it did
like that for me flipped the switch
where i went oh
this is the future of gaming it is the
future of social interaction it is it is
so much beyond
what i thought and uh the leaps and
bounds in the tech over just the last
couple years
uh so that's why i ultimately went to
oculus and i'm really happy to be there
um but if you really care if you want to
follow me i am at walla bill
uh because i'm also a hockey guy goalie
yeah and
i'm bored because i'm fat one of the two
but thanks for having me on and uh this
is a ton of fun i hope we could do it
again
final fantasy 7. oh oh wait wait we
joined forces
my man built backwards yes help man
which final fantasy is the best yeah
that's the next
they're final fantasy 6 guys oh oh my
god
i thought you were going to say 10 or so
that's like being trying to be counter
culture
you know that's another debate
it's very easy to roll with the masses
isn't it
and final fantasy 7 is one of my top
five games of all time it's
it's literally the reason i bought a ps
what was it
it was the reason i actually started
playing rpgs in the first place i
remember seeing those commercials those
you know those
places like and i said and i never
played an rpg before in my life
well that's the problem yeah i don't
know
i can only speak from my experience
i've played through final fantasy vii
like eight times it's like
it's such an amazing experience did you
think it was an action game before you
actually played it
no i mean i knew it was your argument
that seven is an action game come on no
no
no no no i'm just saying the way they
marketed seven made it
like it wasn't what it was although i
already got super chats coming in
now
i will say i do have a a very uh soft
spot in my heart
for final fantasy viii okay it's just
the it's the gun thing
it's the water gun thing so i'm gonna
give a chance to do this roll out
me two and final fantasy game times
patrick two dollars super chat
every two in ff6 just saying you got
half of it right sir yeah
is that everything yeah we're good
fantastic show jets
catch us tomorrow to be back sunday 1
p.m eastern we will have chase money
we'll talk some games have some fun this
is fantastic
catch you guys later peace